I think my favorite thing is just seeing
how the life of a scientist is every day
so every day coming into the lab having
to plan out which we're going to do and
that independence that goes with it and
also the teamwork that goes with it I
guess the most fun thing for me right
now is that all the field trips that we
go on because of the swabbing that I am
doing so I'm going around New York
swabbing different places to look at the
bacteria that lives there and I'm
getting too well to Governors Island I'm
getting too well to subway stations
taking ferry and this up bringing many
new experiences to me I like that it's
creative yet also analytical because I'm
someone who's definitely into the arts
and I think that science is extension
I want to help as many teachers as
possible because honestly teachers are
truly the gateway for science they are
the ones who are every day at the front
lines bringing students interest and
opening their eyes to the wonders that
is sciencing
I like the freedom and how we could
really at least in my lab we really got
to decide what we wanted to do and we
got to come up with our own experiments
and decide what we want to test so more
freedom in critical thinking on your own
I really like the balance of having to
figure things out on your own and
learning by assembly trial and error and
the amount of support that we are given
in terms of being shown how procedures
were where to research how to think
about things really which is a lot of
critical thinking that goes into what we
do we are committed to making sure that
the science outreach program will reach
as broad community as possible the
community that Rockefeller houses is one
that is creative generous and extremely
bright
I was expecting to learn field work
research work and actually got a lot
more out of it I gotta think like a
scientist I got to plan project like a
scientist the developed question like
how a scientist does but I definitely
want to be able to use science and use
other things i will learn along the way
not to be able to impact the world and
make it a much better place for
everybody